hello and it's fantastic to see you here
how you enjoying it so far in the UK
well right now we're in I believe the
oldest moded house in the UK called Noir
so were on cloud 9 considering we live
in you know construction that was built
three years ago yeah a little bit
different huh it's gorgeous it's
absolutely phenomenal so we're having
quite a time now it's great to hear that
now of course season four of Teen Wolf
is going on as we speak lots and lots of
excitement of course as it always is
with team walls new season how do you
compare shooting this one to season
three well we have quite a different
cast this season so there is a bit of a
I call it Saved by the Bell new class
going going on this season I also like
that the villains there's quite a few of
them in this season and in the past
there's been more of them quite a little
few side bits that lead up to one sort
of super villain and in this season it's
not quite the case there's there's more
develop side plots going on than usual
so there's why didn't fill in in
particular that has no mouth called the
mute that is my personal favorite
because he's so scary yeah what is it
you like about in particular it's just
the fact that he he terrorizes families
in the night and that's my biggest fear
you know my biggest fear is not so much
being taken over by a mummy in my head
or a werewolf but but more the practical
fears which this villain has and he was
the benefactor as well haven't you we do
that's I would probably say the biggest
villain of this season but you meet
quite a few along the way to get to to
get to Candyland so to speak yeah we
actually spoke to Joe Gans earlier this
year he's fantastic isn't he was it like
working with him he's fun he's fun I
mean I can't tell you if I had a lot of
scenes with him or not
which villains I have seen something I
don't but you know all of our guest cast
that comes on Teen Wolf is is quite
special and we're honestly just lucky to
have them because I don't know why they
would you know they deserved their
leading roles
I am just so grateful that we have such
a great supporting cast now I've got a
few questions as well as well as my own
from our friends and fans on the
internet and struck my Styles asked me
to ask you what's the toughest thing
that you've done on Teen Wolf so far I
would say the screaming and Lydia is
always quite dramatic she's pretty
intense emotional scenes and so as an
actor you go from laughing about weird
looking hot dogs that are at crafty to
you know very intense scenes that you
you honed sort of the the art of
switching back and forth mentally and so
I would say that's probably the biggest
obstacle that I've overcome in Teen Wolf
is it's it's really a walk in the park
now because I've been doing it for four
years now how is the punchiness going so
far this season for you there is a lot
of screaming but not necessarily for me
someone like who I can get intriguing I
liked it I liked it if you could get the
Lydia any advice for this season or even
the future what would you say to her you
take her signs in Lydia really there's a
bit of a family scrapbook in the making
or being discovered I should say and so
I would just tell her to brace herself
because you haven't seen a lot of
Lydia's backstory yet and this season we
was well into that more excitement and
intrigue our limit now which carrot if
you could spend any more screen time we
would you love to spend more screen time
with always the same it's coach and love
coach um Deaton's quite fun as well Seth
he I think I wish I could say in
retrospect that Aiden and Lydia would
have had more of a chemistry on-screen I
mean they hardly had a relationship it
wasn't really a relationship in my
opinion but I would say as far as who's
on screen now I would say coach or demon
I'm what about the opposite of that what
about facing off with someone if you
could face off with
any character on the show who would you
like to go up against I would say a girl
fight I think that's fun and not the
pulling of the hair and the name-calling
kind of girl fight I want a real fight
yes a kick-ass fight with real stunt
coordinators any potentially even stunt
doubles there is there was a really fun
stuck actually didn't get to do this
season though so as I say I actually had
to meet the stunt coordinator because
Lydia doesn't usually do get to do that
how did he find doing that then it was
amazing I don't know if I can tell what
kind of standard wise but I'm involved
pyrotechnics and there's a big stunt
there's some wires it was fun so you'd
like more of that for future please oh
it was amazing it's you put on a
different thinking cap when you go into
stunts on a set and you can see why
people that Tom Cruise really makes that
it's Forte because it's it's a different
muscle you're using no pun intended then
than just traditional acting scenes and
so you know if you do the first half of
the day
regular acting and then you're doing
stunts the second half the day it's
quite fun it's just different it's like
going out for PE during school I live
that comparison if you could be any
other character on the show who would
you like to be and why and that comes
from Teen Wolf talk it's so boring
I was a therapist coach I think which is
really funny and I love I didn't grow up
initially with PE teachers that were
also our gymnasium teachers gym head
what did you say that in UK we say
piggies yeah and as well as regular
teachers like a math teacher English
teacher and so I only discovered that at
like my last couple years of high school
when I switch schools and so I think
that's quite interesting that Coach has
to you know do the La Crosse thing as
well as the cross-country thing as well
as a god I believe he's a math teacher
bit of everything definitely now we've
had a question from o'brosey though who
was also known as Styles is hair and
they want to know
steadier Australia and we want to know
why and why not which one of those I
think it's it's sort of pleading the
fifth where I'm in the bubbles so I
can't really see outside of the bubble
so I have to leave that up to the fans I
mean I would have a few reasons for both
and so I guess time will tell I mean I
think like I said yeah we have Cydia has
histories Talia I think they have great
chemistry
Lydia of course would say studia I think
she always wants to win but as an actor
I really don't have an opinion because I
mean I'm sort of I'm inside of it so I'm
in the belly I can't I can't see what
the belly looks like what do you think
when you kind of see fans chanting have
you see them online or if they tweet you
and stuff like that and it's about those
kind of issues I mean I'm on that side
of the coin so everyone's like sitting
up forever I'm sure I'm sure Shelley
gets a lot of you know screws Diddy is
diet so you know we're really you know
off in left field of like fanfiction
hybrids so I I think whatever the fans
in deep wanting and there's also the of
course the aspect just tiny bit of
aspect of what Geoff Wright just a
little bit so I guess time will tell if
you could ship any other characters in
the show not involving Lydia Hughie do
use ship come up with a new one let's
say like coach and Kate argent so what
would that be like what would that be
coach in car gent Cote cogent no cogent
so we'll go ahead and like you know it
can be Junior arcade coach it let's make
it happen
and what would you like to see happening
for Lydia in future going forward more
of what sorry starting to happen in
season four so you could understand why
she is the way she is why she is is
steadfastly stubborn and intelligent and
a bit of a loner you know she didn't
have a lot of friends before Alison came
along we have an isolated girl so I
think it
certain the reasons why she's all of
those things and you know she at the end
of the day what I love about Lydia is
she always is selfish and narcissistic
'she is and delusional as she is she
always really does want to help the
situation and these had become a real
friends so I would say just more of that
I would say more Baxter to understand
who she is as a person
now do you think we're gonna see more of
her wanting just to be with just one guy
or do you think she's gonna continue how
to love him and leave him unless she did
in the past I would hope she's gonna
settle down soon she's almost a senior
in high school guys I mean I you know
it's about time to put a ring on it
no I mean Holland I will be single
forever but but I think Lydia would be
the type to probably house wipe it
pretty soon you know but she'd always be
the one like has it all kind of thing
she probably always working you know
have her like little Stepford wife
childhood and it was like 27
there's no that I don't know you could
turn pair off with anyone on the show
who do you pair off with with what male
and a pair of probably say styles just
because I think their marriage would be
quite fruitful II fun you would just be
always it would never be boring Stiles
and Lydia now was it like working with
those guys behind the scenes Tyler P&A
you got dinner and though you had
Kristin of course Max and Charlie as
well so gone I mean there's a different
experience with all of them I think with
the core of our cast when we first
started they you know Tyler and Dylan I
describe to my high school they were
boys and we've got Christopher I've
gotten to see them really grow up and so
that's been really fun to watch their
evolution Colton's always a blast I
first looked at him oh god I love it is
this pretty boy know about and he is
course oh my gosh his personality is not
match his looks he is such a goofball
and such an incredible human being who
was one of my very good friends to this
day
Declan and I have actually known each
other for years
before the show started we were set up
on a blind date years ago through our
best friends that did not work out well
actually I had that same night
suggesting he he date my friend so he's
always been sort of a bug a brother like
relationship and then you know the twins
Max and Charlie we they've six before
but they leave awake wherever they go
they're the most just fascinating human
beings there I've never met people and
this is gonna sound so cliche coming
from twins or about twins but they are
so alike but different but alike but
different it's hilarious to watch their
dichotomy but they're also they were
poor together is it's just that's never
boring
um but yeah I would say the twins make
quite the impression on you and yeah I
mean we're all really good friends you
know I mean crystal and I we have a lot
in common it's what kind of clothes we
like and what kind of movies we like and
how we see the world and we have a very
honest relationship with each other
which is what I appreciate with with
crystal and and you it's honestly
sometimes hard to find now with
actresses and I don't know why I went to
an all-girl school for 11 years so it
was a new thing for me to be like what
quad they're all the girls friends yeah
that was that was different for me and
so to find crystal in this business is
really a blessing that you know you have
somebody that's almost like a sister
like relationship buddy even if you
don't talk for a little while you come
back together it's licking feet you
haven't left and so uh so yeah we're all
very good friends that look the whole
line of all the relationships it's been
like losing crystal from the show then
going forward it's been hard of course
it's been hard I'm happy for her because
she's moving on to other projects and
you know crystal they're pretty much
common knowledge at this point that were
a little bit older than the boys I'm
five years older than the boys so we're
discovering life different were in our
late 20s and so playing sixteen
seventeen isn't quite as interesting as
it used to be for us
you know we've sort of finished that
portion of our lives
um and and so you know I think she
wanted to be my daughter other projects
where she could be emotionally and
professionally satisfied with the kind
of care she was playing but she had a
blast playing Alison
it was it's just a job that you can
never recreate so that doesn't mean we
gonna lose you as well no I love Teen
Wolf I absolutely loved him but you
never know on this show it gets crazy
Lucy lost Daniels last season but was
even like saying goodbye to him but also
he didn't die and like crystals
character did did he
so he could return I guess you never
know what the I know I I didn't mention
Daniel earlier but Daniel is a very good
friend of mine very you know we're all
really are really good friends off
screen and so he's little Wildcat he's
so much fun he's crazy but I love
watching his craziness and I see him so
much off screen that it doesn't feel
like he left so I'm like shiny wet so
weird it's like yeah I'm not another job
now I go to Atlanta so we uh we get to
seem quite a bit so we actually don't
miss too much and of course you also had
a visit not that in the distant future
in the distant past I should say from
Colton recently didn't you had a visit
from Colton Haynes on set yeah and he
was tweeting and the photos and stuff
and saying hey what's going on here on
Teen Wolf I'm back it's so funny because
I forget that people see those things
like I'm like oh yeah we Instagram
dating so he yeah we were talking one
day it come in he's been out of town
like five straight months and I think
he's been in telling ten days in Los
Angeles and since January and he was in
town for a few days and I went and hung
out with him till like 4:00 o'clock in
the morning else wrap I have work at
like 6:30 I got two hours of sleep slept
on his couch and went back to work cuz
he lives pretty close to where I shoot
and so he thought oh just drop by it was
that Cavalier it was nothing don't read
and do it guys there's nothing to it he
literally was just down the street from
set and thought I'm in town I love
seeing Holland I want to see everybody
else and he just dropped by of course he
got everyone in at is it near what are
the chances Colton's gonna return so of
course you've got to ask you even though
what you've just said what are the
chances cause we're debt I think it's
zero you will turn to set to visit I'm
sure but that's I mean that's how nice
it is I mean Daniel comes to set
colton comes to set I'm sure at some
point crystal will come to set it's
really a family and it's it's funny what
takes place off screen it's just our
life so yeah and Teen Wolf Levy wanted
me to ask you how much do the Teen Wolf
cast hang out and what about the old and
new cast you guys still hang out as well
right it's so funny one of our executive
producers there were today me TV was
lost the Live Love II he was actually
who cast me it was like the deciding
factor he's like okay let's go with that
girl so I like that screen name yeah I
mean the new cast is great I've actually
I've known Shelley before we started the
show or she was on the show as well
through through to the front of ours and
the girl I know and then Arden was I did
not know her before us so um it's been
great it's it's more of a professional
set now because we grew up together
initially but all of the actors are
lovely to work with and what about what
you get up to between tanks because I
remember when we spoke to Colton last
year chatting a little bit about cuz
I've obviously left a team off by then
the pranks and things that you guys used
to get out to there's not as many pranks
anymore no there was one during the
finale this year that somebody hidden
someone's trailers or something like
that but you know having having Jill
Wagner back on set is a lot of fun she
is a blast to be around and so she
actually kind of keeps things fresh and
fun and and that's always a joy but but
no it's it's it's very professional now
almost like a regular show now because
prior it was definitely not a regular
show
I mean the things that Dillon and Tyler
I think say it's still a little bit but
getting to very interesting
conversations right before their roles
so their mics are on and oh boy it's
like 18 year old boy conversation for
the world to hear and I think people
that visit center like what is going on
action and it's right to the scene and
so it's it's comical it's fun you know
but since the beginning of the show it's
been it's been a little bit more
professional now we talked about Colton
of course and he's left for our big
superhero TV show which member kind of
went would you like to be involved in
like a big TV or movie superhero
franchise like that because there's so
many of them now is loads on TV lots
more to come as well and loads in the
movies as well I mean I think if the
story was there for me I like movies
that have absolutely no action as far as
what I generally like but as far as what
I want to work on I think that if the
story was there which you have people
like Marc Webb and Zack Snyder you are
putting more story based superhero plot
lines into these big studio films so I
really enjoy that I think hiring people
like I'm a STONER Andrew Garfield who
are not your archetypes that would
usually scream superhero is a good move
I think that it's great they're
accessible intelligent we're human
beings playing those kind of roles a
little bit reminiscent of I think Tobey
Maguire and Kristen Dunst so I would
love to be a part of a franchise like
that of course I mean any actor who's
going to receive this her paycheck it's
like I'll pass thanks guys
but I I do like that they put sort of
the spider-man franchise on his head and
made it this a solid effort to me the I
haven't seen the current spider-man but
the last spider-man movie was almost
reminiscent of think this little indie
film and they had such an intimate
rapport with each other in the midst of
this big action-packed world and I
hadn't I haven't seen that that before
that that barometer before it was
interesting you mentioned spider-man
actually because I'm Colton did
he I think he lost he retweeted someone
who said that you would be a great MJ
did you think about that I don't see he
thought you'd be great MJ as well okay
so I I get on Twitter I definitely I
mean it's not that I'm like one of those
people that shuns Twitter I think you
have to adapt with the times and you
know of course they have an Instagram
and Twitter I'm an actor you have to
have those things but I don't get on it
as much as I should and and I don't say
that in like one of those anti Hollywood
ways I just genuinely don't get on as
much as I should and I should I should
get on and more and so I was out of town
part of that time for almost three weeks
because whenever we rap I usually take a
vacation and so that happened in the the
three week time period and then I got
home and was getting back into my swing
of things and it was right before Comic
Con so at that point it's been a month
and I got on Twitter I was like I need
to I need Comic Con and it was just like
an explosion of this mary-jane stuff and
I'm thinking what is happening where did
this start and around that same time it
took it took a few weeks but my mob list
has started calling me my manager
started calling me and asking if it was
real because they had media calling them
and I'm thinking oh god this is terrible
I know it's not real and so at Comic Con
they said that's a good place to say
because it was you know a few days out
they said just say it's a you know set
the record straight I said I would be
happy to and so yeah it's funny how
rumors get started but I I mean Colton's
always joked about all the redheaded
parts in Ariel Wonder Woman in some I
know she's a brunette and some she's a
redhead so he's always just joking about
redheaded parts and that's where that
came from I think and it's funny I
actually saw Marc Webb at a party during
that memorable rumor but no there's no
truth absolutely not we loved watching
you in Teen Wolf long may it continue
and we look forward to seeing the rest
of season 4 thanks so much for talking
to us today hello thank you appreciate
you